bonjour à vous général les Américains
donc franchissent un nouveau cap ce
système de défense est présenté comme
l'équipement militaire le plus
sophistiqué qu'est-ce qu'il a de
particulier
la particularité des micelles patriotes
c'est que ce sont des missiles qui sont
chargés essentiellement d'arrêter les
missiles qui sont envoyées c'est à dire
pas tellement les drones mais plutôt les
missiles
perfectionnées
de prendre ça de très très loin qui est
annonce un peu fracassante sur l'arrivée
de ces missiles c'est vrai que de la
part des Américains c'est le système le
plus perfectionné qu'ils peuvent donner
aujourd'hui simplement il va permettre
de compléter la panoplie de la défense
anti-aérienne ukrainienne qui
aujourd'hui
donc ça amènera peut-être à 85 90%, mais
c'est un système compliqué à mettre en
oeuvre et donc ça n'est pas pour demain
mais plutôt pour après-demain si j'ai
bien compris les Américains vont livrer
un le système patriote est-ce que c'est
pas un peu
limité pour changer la donne
bien sûr c'est limité ça ne changera pas
d'honneur ça permettra peut-être de
protéger un site stratégique comme
peut-être qui est par exemple avec ses
missiles mais je le répète il faut
former les équipages dessus on parle de
la Pologne ou l'Allemagne pour les
équiper pour les entraîner et ensuite
les déployer donc on ne les voit pas
arriver en avant le mois de février
peut-être mars mais j'espère en février
mais je le répète c'est un complément ce
qu'il faut voir sur l'aspect
psychologique de cette affaire là c'est
que les patriotes étaient critiqués par
les États-Unis depuis longtemps puisque
leur déploiement en Pologne par exemple
les Russes considéraient ça comme une
avancée de l'automne vers la Russie
aujourd'hui ils vont se déployer
directement en Ukraine donc pas très
loin de la frontière russe mais
rappelons-le ces missiles ont pour objet
de protéger la population contre les
attaques russes donc c'est pas une
agression américaine c'est une
protection de la population
ukrainienne fournie par les Américains
contre les attaques faites par les
Russes néanmoins les Russes générales
parlent ce jeudi de guerre indirecte
est-ce qu'il y a pas le risque que les
Américains apparaissent de plus en plus
partie prenante au conflit un risque de
corrigérance non alors le fait qui est
une implication directe des États-Unis
les Russes n'ont pas complément tort
mais il faut rappeler que c'est eux qui
ont agressé ce sont eux qui ont poussé
les Américains à rentrer en protection
de l'Ukraine je rappelle que l'Ukraine
est agressé ses frontières
internationales franchies par les Russes
en contrebravation de l'article 51 enfin
plutôt de la Charte des Nations Unies et
donc les Américains comme les Européens
ne font qu'appliquer l'article 51 qui
est la protection d'un pays qui est
agressé donc ne n'aversons pas la preuve
ce sont les Russes qui sont fautifs de
cette agression et les Américains bien
sûr et la visite de Monsieur
Washington bien sûr
Marc l'engagement direct des Américains
et donc d'une certaine façon une
confrontation entre les Russes et les
Américains par ukrainien interposé on
parle bien de système défensif les
Américains refusent de livrer d'autres
armes des systèmes offensifs il y a
vraiment une lumière rouge
alors écoutez ça me fait toujours rire
quand on parle des systèmes offensifs et
défensifs faudra qu'on m'explique les
imars sont défensifs ou offensifs ça ne
tient pas la route si vous voulez autant
on peut le dire pour les patriotes ce
sont des systèmes défensifs puisque sont
des systèmes anti-aériens autant il y a
d'autres systèmes qui sont naturellement
des systèmes qui peuvent être offensifs
comme les aymars les Césars ou d'autres
systèmes mais il y a des armes que les
Américains refusent pour l'instant de
livrer aux Ukrainiens par peur que le
conflit ne s'étendent alors en
particulier les imams avec des capacités
de missiles qui tiraient à 350 km sont
refusés par les Américains ce que les
Américains souhaitent c'est que les
Ukrainiens se servent de ce matériel
pour se défendre donc c'est globalement
la défense
à l'intérieur de leur frontière il ne
souhaite pas que les Ukrainiens
utilisent ces armements pour frapper la
Russie sur le territoire russe c'est la
limite qui est mise par les Américains
actuellement et ce ne sont pas les seuls
les Européens ont les mêmes limites
merci beaucoup général de Minnie
trinquant pour vous explications sur
France 24